Welcome to the Man of Recaps.
This is The Walking
Dead: Daryl Dixon, season one.
If you haven't watched it yet,
don't spoil yourself
here, Click the link in the description
and sign up for AMC+.
binge through all of season one.
Now At the end of The Walking Dead,
our group finally found long term safety
at their new super group,
the Commonwealth.
But Daryl Dixon didn't stick around,
he hopped on his motorcycle
and rode out to explore
the rest of the zombie apocalypse.
Now Daryl's own series starts
right off with him shipwrecked and washing
ashore,
somehow he's made it all the way to
So Daryl's off on a French adventure,
trying to find a boat back home.
But the zombies here in France, “les
affamés” ,
the hungry ones, are more dangerous
than Daryl's used to,
They got weird variants,
like some of them are burning hot zombies
So Daryl makes some friends,
luckily everyone in France speaks English.
When some bad guys show up, Daryl helps
fight them off.
But his new friends
knock him out and rob him anyway.
But Daryl’s rescued by some new friends,
yes they're nuns.
The main
nun, Isobel, gives Daryl the tour.
And yeah,
that's the cool thing about zombie
Apocalypse Europe,
You got all these castles
that were designed to be self-sustaining
before electricity.
There's a kid living here, Laurent,
who's a real gentle soul.
And he and Daryl hit it off
because they both have long hair.
But these nuns believe Laurent is real
special: the second coming, the Messiah!
Daryl is like, “Yeah, right.
Good luck with that.
I'll see you later.
Crazy nuns.”
The bad guys are investigating
their last patrol,
they're led by face
tattoo guy called Codron.
One of the guys killed was his brother,
and this girl blames it all on Daryl.
So Codron and his men storm the nunnery,
Daryl's got to help defend them.
Although these nuns are far
from defenseless, oh!
It's an epic killer
nun That's another cool
thing about France, by the way,
They don't have a lot of modern guns
laying around,
so they're fighting with cool
old timey guns and medieval weaponry.
Now, these nuns are part of a larger
good guy group, the Union of Hope,
and they want to get Laurent up
to their base in the north.
And apparently there's a port nearby
with working ships.
So, Monsieur Daryl is escorting Laurent
and Isabelle on a cross France adventure.
Along the way
there's a couple of fun adventures,
like this group of kids
who grew up here in their preschool.
They’re
fighting an American who's taken over this
castle,
and Daryl falls into his zombie moat.
Then there's a conductor
who's built himself a zombie orchestra!
All right, that's new.
But soon they make it to the big city,
welcome to Paris.
The Union of Hope has a good base
here, led by And while Laurent is probably
not the real Messiah,
he is a nice kid and gives them hope.
So to buy Daryl a boat ticket home,
they go to Paris's hottest
underground zombie apocalypse nightclub.
The club's owner is this English
guy Quinn, who also has long hair.
In fact, he looks exactly like Daryl
if he brushed it back.
And turns out
Quinn is Isabelle's ex-boyfriend.
Yeah, she wasn't always a nun.
Before the zombie apocalypse,
she was a bit of a party girl
and also a bit of a thief.
There's a real cool episode
where we follow Isabel
the night the zombie apocalypse started,
and as you imagine, things got bad
real quick.
She and Quinn were heading out of town,
They stopped to pick up Isabelle's
pregnant sister, Quinn was like, “Yo,
she's slowing us down,
we got to ditch her.” But Isabel wasn't
having that ditched him instead.
They ended up at the convent,
but unfortunately her
sister died in childbirth.
but when her body reanimated as a zombie,
she was able to finish giving birth!
And that's Laurent,
so it was a miracle birth.
But now that Quinn meets Laurent, he
reveals a secret: he is Laurent’s father!
He wants Laurent and Isabel to join him
and be a happy family.
But it's like, “Yo,
you cheated on me with my sister,
then tried to ditch her
in the zombie apocalypse.
You're kind of a douche.”
But there's a bigger bad guy out there,
Madam Genet,
who runs the supergroup
that loosely controls all of France.
She controls the port with the trans
Atlantic ships
that Daryl Dixon rode in on,
and now we finally get that story.
Daryl was cruising around
America on his motorcycle.
He stopped to get gas
from this French scientist
who was paying fuel in exchange
for rounding up live zombies.
By the way they had a radio here, so Daryl
checked in with his best friend, Carol.
They had a bad connection,
but she said someone came back.
Who came back?! We got to know!
Daryl befriended this kid here,
but one of the other guys killed him.
So Daryl picked a fight.
But there's a strict
no fighting policy here, so strict
in fact that if you break it, you're
loaded onto the ship to be zombie meat.
But Daryl is not going out like that,
Eventually he escaped
But whatever experiments they're doing on
these zombies makes them fast and strong.
Daryl has got to abandon ship.
So yeah, it’s Genet who's really excited
about these experiments
to make zombies stronger.
And she's mad at the American “Dixon”
who ruined her ship,
so she sends her goons to hunt him down.
Laurent got separated, so they meet up at
the big Paris landmark, the Eiffel Tower.
Unfortunately,
even in the zombie apocalypse, it's
real crowded with tourists.
But now Genet has locked down the city,
they need Quinn's help to escape.
So Isabelle
agrees to be his girlfriend again
in exchange for getting Daryl
and Laurent out of the city.
But Quinn already has a girlfriend
who's none too
pleased he's swooning over his ex.
So she turns him in to Genet,
and Daryl in the Laurent, are caught.
So Genet learns how this whole group
thinks Laurent is the Messiah kid.
So she wants to control Laurent
and have him endorse her
as president of France.
And indeed
tonight's her inauguration party,
where the main event is the American Daryl
Dixon in a zombie gladiator battle.
But it's just one zombie,
that's no big deal, except they shoot it
with the special injector dart.
They supe it up with the zombie
steroids, oh!
This one might be a problem.
But Daryl's a pro,
he still takes this thing out.
For round two
they chain him and Quinn together,
the Long Haired Duo versus
four super zombies.
These zombie steroids are still a work
in progress,
sometimes they don't work at all.
And on this other one, it makes them
so violent it attacks another zombie.
Working together, Daryl and Quinn
take the other two zombies out.
Daryl's like, “Are you not entertained!?”
and chucks this zombie
head right at Genet.
Now the resistance causes a distraction
so Daryl can try to escape.
Quinn was injured
though, he’s slowing them down.
And now he wants to do right
by Isabelle and Laurent.
So he has Daryl cut off his hand,
so he can separate and buy him time.
But then it's awkward
when Zombie Quinn catches up to Isabelle.
Daryl gives Lauren
the battle
axe, “God will forgive you, kid.”
As he kills his first zombie,
who is his father.
And so it looks like
they're out of danger,
but danger
catches up to them, it's Codron.
He wants to kill Daryl
and avenge his brother.
But Genet's orders were to kill Laurent
and the nuns, too.
And Cauldron is a badass, but a good guy,
So he shoots the other goons instead!
“Monsieur Dixon, I will see you later.”
So our group completes the journey
to the Nest, which turns out is the famous
landmark Mont St.
Michelle.
So they're safe at the headquarters
of the Union of Hope,
this multi-religious, peaceful group
led by this guy Losang.
But of course Genet
is going to come for them eventually.
She figured out Codron betrayed her,
So he's imprisoned, we'll see him later.
So Daryl settles in for a bit, peeling
potatoes, making sexy eyes with Isabelle.
Yes these two have a blossoming romance.
But Daryl is not sticking around,
they found him a boat back to America.
But he's meeting the boat
at the Normandy Beach,
where there is the cemetery
of American soldiers who died here
in World War Two, including Daryl Dixon's
grandfather.
It's a touching moment
as Daryl reflects on history, and how
sometimes life takes you far from home,
but that's where you need to be.
So Daryl decides he can't go home yet.
He's got to stay in France
and see this through.
Meanwhile, back in America,
some random dude is on Daryl's bike.
And he's chased down by Daryl's
best friend, Carol.
she's like, “Hey, that's my friend's
bike, “where'd you get it?”
But he doesn't want to talk,
he tries to rob her.
So she knocks this guy out,
ties him up in the trunk, like, “Hey,
let's try that again.”
So yes, Carol is coming to find Daryl!
Will she make it all the way to France?
And that's where The Walking Dead: Daryl
Dixon season one comes to an end.
Yes season two is confirmed,
Daryl's adventure is just getting started!
There's a link in the description
where you can sign up for AMC+.
Binge through all of season one now.
I gave you the quick recap, but there's
a lot of great stuff I couldn't cover.
It's a cool new setting in Zombie France
full of unique exciting
new zombie encounters.
Will Daryl
finally find love with Isabelle?
What is Madame Genet's end
game with the super zombie experiments?
And of course, Carol is joining the show.
Can't wait to see her back in action!
So click the link in the description
and sign up for AMC+ now.
Join in for The Walking Dead: Daryl Dixon,
and the rest of the expanded
Walking Dead Universe.
If you like this recap
hit that subscribe button for more of the
best recaps of TV and movies.